you know this is a good time to bring up
maybe uh
the pardon today oh michael flynn yeah
yeah
this is scary that's a scary stuff why
is it scary uh not the pardon
oh i think the partner was the right
move it's scary that
judge sullivan so so i'll give you the
quick context uh
michael flynn was charged with lying to
the fbi but it was an informal meeting
he wasn't actually in an official
meeting under an official investigation
as far as he knew
he's hanging out at the white house and
some guys in the question you ever
talked to kislyak and he was like no
and they're like gotcha you lied and
they said plead guilty otherwise we're
going after your son
and so he said okay once trump got
control of things he said
we're going to drop this case the judge
said no
they tried again judge sullivan started
prosecuting essentially
refusing the prosecution to drop their
case it makes no sense
and then here's the funniest part the
most infuriating thing
over the past month do you know what
judge sullivan has done nothing
nothing you know why sullivan is waiting
for joe biden to get in
so they can lock up michael flynn for no
reason
because he offended the delicate
sensibilities of the political
establishment by working with donald
trump that's it
they used him as a weapon against trump
they threatened his family
and trump is pardoning him now this is a
political civil war and that that
language came from
came from mother jones yeah they said
the political civil war will carry on
when you have the obama administration
falsely
targeting a national enacting national
security adviser who was doing his job
targeting his family and we saw it from
the notes that got released the fbi said
what's our goal here to prosecute him or
get him fired
the fact that they even questioned
getting him fired proves that their
intention was just to
hurt donald trump's campaign yes that's
it or his administration yeah
and with the underlying motivation of
protecting themselves
right because flynn was the one who knew
where the skeletons
were buried or which closets the
skeletons were in something like that he
knew
where the bodies were there we go yeah
he knew where the bodies were literally
and figuratively
yeah 100 and uh it definitely derailed
things and it also put trump in a really
bad position
where he you know he fired him and then
he looked bad he didn't look loyal to
his people and he threw out
sort of uh a a dynamic guy who wanted to
make change in the right way who saw the
world the right way
was part of the whole team that was
supposed to make changes and that was a
huge fumble and a huge a huge win
basically for the democrats there and uh
it just reminds me actually of why the
presidential pardon exists in some cases
i mean
you had to people had to believe that
they would use the courts against your
political
you know allies as a way to get to you
so like of course
people that support the president are
going to be attacked and this is a way
to you know maybe protect somebody
in that regard i'm not an expert on
president pardon so i'm just spitting
yeah it does seem weird that uh
he pled guilty then they tried dropping
it it's like the case is already
it's like did i already get to that
point like where were we at but it's
weird like you can pardon someone before
they've been investigated or charged or
something like
yeah i'm not i'm not an expert on that
all i know is i wish that he would have
done that sooner
brought him he wanted to get reelected
he didn't want to rock the boat
who was advising this guy if he would
have pardoned
flynn more people would have come out
and supporters if trump came out
in the first debate with the when they
said your last and final statement
i donald j trump am going to completely
legalize through executive order
on my first day of re-election january
21st
i will completely legalize cannabis
nationwide and pardon all non-violent
drug offenders
if that was that last thing he said he's
like 120 million votes i have been
saying that since 2016 one of the survey
questions
in the survey i did for democrats are
deplorable the last question bonus
question
do you think that cannabis should be
decriminalized at the federal level
and it was like 75 to 25 of democrats to
deplorable voters
supported it it would have been a huge
win i called for it i
even told all my contacts in the white
house i've been pushing for it i mean
don't have the influence to get that
done
but i tried i tried because it's a civil
liberties issue
it's a it's a civil rights issue you
know it's a liberty
issue i mean also it's just seen and
smart so yeah and it generates a lot of
revenue through taxation i mean
it would have been it would it would
defang a lot of cartels which it already
started has started to do you know you
know what's really crazy
you know the cartels are selling now
i don't want to know is it getting worse
uh
make a guess they're selling so so i'm
not
a barber tall so now that now that pot
is basically recreational in many
different states yeah
you're wrong you're wrong it's way worse
way worse than that yeah avocados
no joke avocados really yep you know
they because avocados are extremely
like in demand lucrative you know
millennials love that avocado toast i
mean avocados are pretty awesome
so they're shaking down avocado farms
now it's more money yeah i mean i i
believe that 100
that those guys aren't dedicated to the
art and the
the act of selling these drugs they're
just trying to if they knew a guy that
bought bricks for 10 and
they could sell bricks for nine or buy
but they would do it they would do it
that way maybe not in that order
uh but yeah he could have done it he
didn't do it there's a lot of things he
could have done didn't do
i i don't know if i'm ready for the
post-mortem although i've been critical
of him every time that he needed it and
i've been supportive when he has
you know i i've never been one to come
out and just throw maga read and meet
and say donald trump is the god
savior and all that he he represented an
opportunity
for us the network to make change
and i i think he was effective in some
ways in that regard and he certainly
certainly stalled some of the things
that we wanted to stall and slow
but was he perfect no and you know the
economic devastation that will come to
this country
in the next uh several months will be
i believe it's going to be coveted
related you mean yeah yeah yeah like
it's going to be unimaginable and then
new administration tim do you really
you really think that the covet
situation is going to be worse
now than it was in march uh
based based on the fact that people are
already had already their legs chopped
off in march
and now they're coming for him again oh
fiscally humane yeah
yeah yeah yeah the lock the so they're
destroying ownership
yeah i mean i'm telling you we got this
uh i got
let me let me pull the story the story
of new covid policing unit
to launch in maryland on thanksgiving
eve they're
high high visibility enforcement efforts
they're calling like they're calling
them like compliance units
state and local police to enforce
compliance
we're literally at a point where the
government against the direct
against the science and and even in some
instances instances against the
direction of the cdc
are destroying the economy here's what
happens
have you noticed that dow jones hit 30
000 points today i sure did
yeah that's real good news for people
with money in in
you know retirement or in their stocks
but younger people
and you know people who are lower class
just got cut off completely
like we're we're at a point where you
can see the stock market skyrocketing
while businesses are being are
collapsing wages are gone because the
jobs are gone
so joe biden says i'm going to trust the
scientists on what we should do
and and who's his advisor is dr
osterholm who said
lock the whole country down for six
weeks remember 15 days below the spread
turned into you know 15 days
10 months and and the goal was just to
ease the burden on the icu
so that we didn't have a bunch of
secondary deaths
because of capacity overloads and one
thing that i have noticed
uh it looks as though that the second
wave in europe isn't resulting in the
same amount of death proportionately as
the first go around
it also looks like they might be peaking
i i understand but just in terms of the
science and the data
is going to show a must more diminished
effect
i think this time and you know they're
going to have therapeutics and we have
treatment and knowledge
they're going to they're going to say oh
that's because the lock down is working
we better double our efforts in in
greece if you want to leave your house
you got to text the cops
let them know why in france you got to
have your papers
where is the rapid disposable test
if we could just where's antifa what do
you mean
the anti-fascist to say the government
cannot come down and lock you in your
home right
no they're cheering for it i guess yeah
where are they where'd they go what
they'll protest some fat old trump
supporter waving a flag
but they turn a blind eye when the
government comes that's locking people
in their houses
larpers with attitudes for sure but i
think
isn't a solution this a rapid test that
you can just take
every day or you can take it when you go
somewhere just test test all the time
this is this would be they're unreliable
we should be focusing on moving well so
i think what's going to end up happening
is we've already saw it with uh i i
think it's pronounced contest or qantas
i don't know it's
q the australian airline if you want to
fly international you got to get your
vaccine
you got to have your your approved
vaccine status and ticketmaster
announced they would list vaccine status
on tickets
if the organizers wanted it so what's
going to happen is people are going to
be like no one's forcing you to get the
covet vaccine but you can't do anything
you can't go to
the store because it's a private
business right this is the same way that
they have really affected the quote
lockdowns as they just made it
so that there was nowhere for you to go
so i think
everything we're seeing is the rich
getting richer
the look man if you want to if if if i
had to buy a stock right now
i'd buy these pharmaceutical stocks you
know got it
people got to get the vaccines they're
already saying they're going to put
vaccine status on on on cards
china wants qr codes on your phone for
the whole world because that's what
they're doing
so uh yeah so guess what company's gonna
make a ton of money i've seen v for
vendetta
you you've seen me veneto right the guys
who who uh who worked at lark hill
bought all the stock in the
pharmaceutical company and then all
became ridiculously wealthy
i'm not saying there's anything to
fairies about the vaccine itself i'm
saying
they've got a government mandate they've
these companies got operation warp speed
and so these pharmaceutical companies
are like we got a guaranteed two billion
dollar contract
invest in that's money like the
company's gonna make money guaranteed
definitely let's talk a little bit more
i i'm not familiar with the details of
warp speed are you
because only only a little bit like they
basically offered up uh
guaranteed contracts to the companies so
some got direct funding
and i think uh pfizer got a guaranteed
contract and did they did they like
strip any of the regulations and
approvals or make it streamlined or
anything like that
i can vaguely say i think so because i
was just having this like i didn't go
through the whole business
you know this realization today that
really the the fda and regulations and
clinical trials and all
that that is what's standing in our way
of ending all this all of this
ending the lockdown ending the social
well i mean we need to we need the
vaccine
yeah i'm saying do you watch utopia dude
i'm the one that told you
i know but it's like did you watch the
new one the new one i did not different
one is
way different in the new one there is a
wealthy you know biotech
guy who wants to create a world with no
racism or sexism or inequality
so he stages a fake pandemic so that
they can ram
through a vaccine without proper
protocols and then the vaccine actually
just sterilizes people right make people
beg
beg to take the vaccine which is the
thing that actually sterilizes them and
then
did have you seen the end yet uh i saw
it
no i fell asleep i think but uh the idea
was
people would beg for it and not realize
for five or ten years
that the next generation so now in dc
there's a story you sent me
yeah they just they just approved ten to
three approved children can get
vaccinated without
the parents knowing yeah whoa so so
imagine this
vaccines can have adverse reactions
that's a fact um
it's it the complications tend to be
rare but they do happen especially if
you've got
you know uh how many people live in dc
seven hundred thousand
in in dc proper like three million maybe
three million no no just in dc probably
seven hundred thousand well actually i
guess if the kid lives outside of dc but
goes to school in dc that's
that could happen right it could so then
you've got uh uh you know a couple
hundred thousand kids maybe
potential there's like eighty thousand
kids in the school district in the
school system dc
so of this eighty thousand there is
possible uh complication that might
arise for sure
the mothers watching their kid convulse
on the floor screaming i don't know
what's going on i don't know what's
going on
she calls 9-1-1 and they say has your
son been given any medication
no he hasn't okay and then they give the
kid a counterindicated medication and
the kid
just explodes right in front of everyone
yeah figuratively i mean when i saw the
headline for that article i didn't think
it was true and it's it and i watched
the video
when you sent me the link of the video
time stamped for my dc city council like
approving some bill like that
it made me laugh that you were paying
that close attention to the dc council a
bunch of jokers
well when i saw that the the story came
out saying the dc city council has voted
they said they plan to finalize a vote
allowing children to get back as young
as 11 get invested
vaccinated without parental consent i
looked up the hearing
yeah and i watched the video of them all
voting on it 10-3
10-3 yeah and it's not even just that
it's without
parental consent but it is a legitimate
conspiracy to keep parents
in uninformed where the the the doctor
can order the vaccine vaccine
for the 11 year old who has given their
quote informed consent
right and then they bill the insurance
company without notifying the parent
and then when the when the insurance
companies send you a statement
they can leave out the description of
benefits so you have no idea
what that service was so the whole
there's no paper trail there's no
anything you're completely cut out
when you go to the hospital they ask if
you've taken any medications recently
you know if you know and there and
there's probably they might tell the kid
like here's what you should or shouldn't
do after
getting this vaccine if the kid has some
kind of complication and the mom doesn't
know
the mom could do something very serious
that could harm the child yeah or or
just the fact that
how can you do that to my child what
what what troubles me
is establishing some notion that an 11
year old can give consent
now i haven't i listen tim you know you
know that we know some people that have
trade and crazy theories and we know
that there's a universe out there for
crazy theories and there's one crazy
theory that i've never given any
credence to which is that
there's some sort of grooming a future
grooming of like
pedophilia right like making it okay for
for adults to have sex with kids which
is obviously the most disgusting thing
you can think of
and i've always discounted i've never
paid attention to it sure there's
there's instances where children are
molested assaulted it's horrible
terrible thing we must stop it
but when you start defining legally the
fact that an 11 year old can give
informed consent to where else can they
give this level of consent at 11 years
old
you know that a very popular social
media app created
they had these stickers work that would
say like new year's and like happy day
and there was one of them that said they
put out a video i think it was snapchat
i could be wrong
it said you know love knows no age
terrible
and people started what saying uh mean
like yeah it's not like maybe you're
trying to say like if you're 50 and
you're dating someone who's 20 it's
kind of weird but like it's legal but
like you're going the wrong way with
this one because that's not what people
here
exactly and so when i brought this up to
some of my friends and family about this
new law in dc which luckily has only
passed the council it still needs
mayoral execution which is probably
going to get but then
luckily in dc we don't have home rule
for real
and so the final law gets approved by
congress i've already started lobbying
sympathetic congressmen
as a way to get senate and uh no it just
gets approved by the house
they're going to approve it it's
democrats
true but there are ways there are
ways to to to do i've seen
independent renegade acting isolated
representatives in the house
affect dcu law because it was their pet
issue they find ways through amendments
or whatever the case may be so i started
lobbying people because i can't let this
happen i tried to explain
to my friends and family what it meant
and they read it
and then they just they come back with
the most charitable
charitable like oh well maybe they
didn't word it the right way or that's
not exactly what they mean
exactly right it's the same thing when
you send people to the old
blm website where it said that they
wanted to disrupt the nuclear family
and blah blah blah i got rid of that now
i know they did yeah and and
you i sent the um the guy that uh that
live streamed the the portland murder
i interviewed him for like an hour and a
half going through his tape back and
forth and at the end
trying to ask him why are you doing this
he's like my daughter's got me roped
into it not roped into it she's teaching
me about it whatever
i was like do you know what it says
you're a family man you're a dad
you you're the center of your family and
you're taking care of your kids and you
believe in the power of fatherhood and
the nuclear family
let's read what it says on black lives
matter website about disrupting the
nuclear family and he read it and he was
like oh they just probably had a bad
editor
it's like they people won't just read
the plain
language on the paper
the the throne was seized a long time
ago by this ideology
and it's interesting because we had uh
hotep jesus on
yeah how was that he was great he was
great um and he was basically saying
that
ian was a pessimist and that ian didn't
trust in people
and that's why like you know it was it
was interesting to say because ian's
usually much more optimistic
but the the general idea is the people
who have
who are in positions of power the
established establishment
they think that people are better off
being told what to do instead of being
given the freedom to do it
michael bloomberg is the perfect example
when he said tax the poor and i don't
mean that hyperbolically he literally
gave a speech about taxing the poor
being the right thing to do
he said we need to tax the poor because
they make terrible decisions
and if we have their money and make the
decision for them they'll be better off
to varying degrees i understand what
he's trying to say i can agree in some
capacity
the problem is the bigger picture is a
decentralized network deciding for
itself will
be infinitely smarter and faster moving
and better than a command economy
yeah i i'm much more in favor i'm in
favor of a mixed economy
like we definitely need a government
that can say hey whoa wow that was a
really bad thing we did
you know the market's going crazy we
need to figure this out before
everything goes nuts
but i don't so i'm not a large fair
capitalist but i also don't think a
command economy with one person
dictating what you should or shouldn't
do makes sense
these people do so bloomberg passes the
tax on sugary drinks
it's like no dude like you you need a
cultural shift
to get people to do to do better you
can't just mandate you can't drink soda
you know what i mean
right you you you figure out the right
way to get people
uh uh like i don't know it's got it's
got to be a cultural shift it's got to
be based upon
giving people the choice to do the right
thing taxing
things but but giving people the choice
to do quote the right thing but
comes with the acceptance that
people are going to do the wrong thing
yep and being prepared for that and
being willing to live with those
consequences
are you an optimist or a pessimist an
optimist would say i think
that in a long enough period of time
humans
have the house advantage 51-49 so the
way a casino works is
sure they don't care if you win they
love it when you win good it's marketing
for them they want you to cheer and so
everyone hears you winning
and then makes them gamble more because
in a long enough time frame the house
always wins because their edge is you
know over a point
that's this the same thing in terms
that's how i view uh giving people free
choice
we've proven consistently that on a long
enough time frame humans
tend towards succeeding very well
actually
and these people don't believe it these
people think humans don't have the edge
and need to be constrained and that
has led to disaster every time it's been
tried every single time
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you